here's a an actual important story The
Daily wire has this report and I can't
read the whole thing but it's worth
going to uh daily wire
dot com to read this kind of a follow-up
from Luke rosiak says a Virginia grand
jury investigating a public school
district's apparent cover-up of the rape
of a Girl by a male student in a girl's
bathroom which made headlines after a
daily wire investigation blasted school
officials for their stunning lack of
transparency and intentional Amnesia in
a much anticipated report released on
Monday in the fact-finding report the
nine person Loudoun County panel
disclosed for the first time that a
teacher's aide walked into the bathroom
while the ninth grade victim was being
raped by our male classmate saw two
pairs of feet under a stalled door but
did nothing
but anyway 91-page report called out
District officials for a host of lapses
that's one way to put it that continued
long after the initial attack the report
stated quote we believe that throughout
this ordeal lcps administrators were
looking out for their own interests
instead of the best interests of lcps
this invariably led to a stunning lack
of openness transparency and
accountability both to the public and a
special ground jury grand jury the
report also found
that the district concealed the nature
of the attack even as the district Was
preparing to impose a controversial new
transgender bathroom policy after the
rape the student was transferred to
another school where he was involved in
multiple incidents of this Behavior
against girls that were known to
officials but until now unknown to the
public the report said even the rapist
on grandmother told officials that he
was a sociopath but little was done the
rapist soon committed another sexual
assault this time in a classroom the
grand jury report was released to inform
the public of its findings based on
subpoenaed documents and testimony
Virginia attorney general Jason Myers
noted in a statement that his office had
requested the grand jury and that it has
not been disbanded meaning it could
bring criminal charges at a later date
um The Daily y report that goes into the
details of the assault that that
happened in the bathroom this is on May
22nd of 2021
uh a male student wearing a skirt anally
raped a ninth grade girl in the girls
bathroom and uh we we knew obviously
about the rape because the daily wires
report
we didn't know that a stu that a teacher
a faculty member
walked into the bathroom in the middle
of it and did nothing
um
the report reveals that in the days
before the bathroom rate a teacher's
assistant wrote to her department chair
that the student quote this is the
rapist
has come into class more than once with
his arm around a girl's neck I've caught
him sitting on other girls laps several
times if this kind of Reckless Behavior
persists I wouldn't want to be held
accountable if somebody should get hurt
so she
wrote this
note to a department chair and then a
few days later this person committed a
rape in one of the bathrooms
um school officials seem more interested
in getting the teacher's aid in trouble
than the student the department chair
questioned the true motivation of the
author
uh the report said the department chair
mentioned the email to an assistant
principal who questioned whether the
author of the email had followed proper
protocol
um and then it goes on to more details
about
what exactly happened uh the the
victim's father shows up to the school
after he finds out what's happened and
he obviously is you know I don't think
words could properly describe a father's
feeling after finding out that their
daughter had been raped but he was you
know to put it lightly Furious
and uh they're more interested in just
like getting him out of there and and he
was stonewalled and and uh then
infamously eventually arrested at a
school board meeting
it says by 3 30 PM of that same day
louden's Chief Operating Officer had
arrived at the school and sent an email
to the superintendent saying
quote the incident at sphs is related to
policy 8 uh 80 40 the policy that would
allow transgender males the right to use
the girl's bathroom
now as I said you you got to go and read
the whole report I mean it says what was
the consequence for this um
for this it says on September 9th 2021
just two weeks into the school year
uh the rapist grabbed the shoulder of a
girl really hard in class tried to take
her computer and asked if she posted
nudes online
the superintendent Deputy superintendent
and superintendent Chief of Staff All
learned at this incident
and knew it was the same individual who
committed the sexual assault at sphs
despite having
a 12-page disciplinary file wearing an
ankle monitor being closely monitored by
the Broad Run principal knowledge of
assistant by the highest administrator
in LSP lcps and a suggestion by the
court services unit that a more serious
punishment be given the rapist was
simply asked to write the following
I will not touch others
I will not ask for photos to include
intimate or provocative
because this was after he committed the
rape was transferred to another school
he's still being aggressive sexually
aggressive with with female students
this is all known his history is known
and after another incident his
punishment is writing that note
and that was it
you know we heard from the left after
Luke rosiak's initial expose that this
case had nothing to do with the bathroom
policies they're looking for ways to
frantically kind of uh
uh get around all of this and one thing
that they said is this is nothing to do
with bathroom policies at all and yet
here we have school officials admitting
privately in writing that the two issues
are indeed related because obviously
they are
there's a there's a rape in your in your
school by a male student in the female
bathroom
and yet you're still pushing through a
policy
that would open up the female bathrooms
to any boy that wants to walk in
obviously it's related but it's about
more than that this is a systemic
failure um fueled by
woke Insanity along with cowardice
incompetence self-preservation
selfishness all the factors that allow
these kinds of things to happen within
institutions
um in fact sex abuse in institutions
whether it's the Catholic church or
Hollywood or the public school system
they always follow the same script
you've got some people lower down the
ladder who notice the problem try to
bring attention to it because the
teacher's aid in this case they're
stonewalled by the bureaucracy the
problem is covered up predators are just
like transferred from one place to
another they bounce bounce around it's
like this game of hot potato between the
various uh you know institutions because
nobody wants to deal with it
and it's always the same story
we have to eventually deal with the fact
that this issue in Loudon
is indeed part of a systemic
problem something that is endemic within
the public school system
that's the next step here
as some of us have been shouting about
for years
there there is a there is a system-wide
sex abuse epidemic in the public school
system it has been going on for
literally decades the Department of
Education itself acknowledged the
problem back in 2004
okay and uh and nothing has been done
about it
so this is this is just
you know this is tip of the iceberg
stuff
and this kind of thing can only happen
in in an institution that has this sort
of systemic problem
eventually we have to we have to deal
with that and you would think that we as
a as a society would be very would be
very um
eager to confront the sex abuse problem
in this public school system considering
that that 50 million kids are in the
system
it's like millions of of us not me but
millions of of us millions of Americans
send our kids in this system every
single day
you think if there's evidence you think
of the Department of Education
themselves
nearly 20 years ago acknowledged that
there is a massive problem of sex abuse
in the school system sex abuse committed
by teachers and sex abuses committed by
students against other students
you'd think that we would we would we
would uh wake up and pay attention
and you have millions of parents saying
my God this is what you know my kid is
potentially being subjected to this
but said we've been uh looking the other
way
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]